to our next speaker Sharon Schneider who
is the founder and CEO of texty oh so I
actually started hearing about text EO
last year from a number of YC alumni who
used and loved text EO so they use text
you to analyze their job postings so so
text EO is used not only by startups but
also by large companies like Johnson &
Johnson and CVS and basically they
analyzed data from job postings from
around the world and they can tell you
which are going to be more successful
so text EO has been around for about
three years and they have raised twenty
nine point five million dollars just
amazing and what I thought was really
cool a really cool detail about them is
that about 50 percent of their team is
female and female or non-binary and
their board is over half female as well
so before yeah I know that I think that
doesn't deserve a round of applause and
so before tech CEO Kieran held product
leadership roles at Microsoft and Amazon
so I'm really excited to have you meet
her today and so welcome Karen hey how
many of you had heard of text EO before
today that'll help me level set oh
that's really exciting
so I'm Kiran I am the founder co-founder
and one of one of the founders on the
CEO of tech co we're gonna go back a
little bit through my journey getting to
text EO and a little bit of our journey
as a company I'm gonna walk you through
today five really important decisions we
made that have massively accelerated us
as Kat just mentioned we're a series B
stage company we raised twenty nine
point five million dollars so far and
three years and three months ago we
didn't exist
okay we were founded in late 2014
thank you so you can do this too right
I'm going to show you when you leave
today you look yes I'm ready so a little
bit about me
too fast there we go um those are some
old pictures of me um I grew up with a
dad who is an engineer he's 78 years old
he's still running his own company he's
totally my hero
right he started it when he was 40 I
started textile when I was 40 so I've
literally seen the entire journey of his
small engineering company my mom was a
writer and I grew up to be an engineer
and a writer and very much formative in
what we do at xeo so when I went to
college I double majored in linguistics
and math which was a really present
combination that I didn't know would be
present at the time and then I continued
on and I got a PhD in natural language
processing and I met someone else here
today who is a graduate of the same
program that I was in so that's really
exciting but really my whole life in one
way or another from childhood all the
way on up was about the statistical
measurement of language with math I
chose linguistics because I didn't want
to pick between math and language I've
always really liked both I've been
coding since I was three I was really
lucky to have a dad who was an engineer
so at my age it was pretty unusual to
have computers in your house when you
were three because I'm in my 40s but we
did I won my first science fair project
in fourth grade by writing an early
dating application that in basic those
of you who are old enough where if you
put in your name and answered some
questions about you it would say the
name of the person in the class that you
were gonna marry right however the
people didn't know about if/then and go
to so it was a really great coincidence
whenever the boy I had a crush on put in
his information it said he was gonna
marry me teacher was a little suspicious
I think the other thing I did a lot as a
kid was I played sports I played sports
forever I still coach my three daughters
in basketball today but sports and
teamwork were a huge part of my
upbringing and it really gave me a major
appreciation for teamwork and
tenacity so if you have daughters get
them into sports it pays dividends
forever um that's me is a little kid
that's me on the upper right in middle
school I've always had a flair for
performance with a mullet by the way
still it was willing to do that and
that's me in grad school with I I don't
know how much we had had to drink at
that party but as I came out of graduate
school I didn't know what I wanted to do
I spent a year just writing and ran out
of money and I had a friend at Microsoft
at the time who said I really think
you'd like working in technology you
should work in software I was like no I
hate all those people I went to grad
school with all those people not
interested in he's like okay but you
said you needed a job I her out of money
like good point
and long story short he was right I am
absolutely a technology and software
person so I wasn't Microsoft for about
eight and a half years and it was a
really good experience for me
I was hired as a computational linguist
building spell checkers and grammar
checkers and by the time I left the
company my my culminating project was
leading bings native integration into
Windows across thousands of people so I
really learned how to build software
always with the product and engineering
focus so when it came to text EO I
understood product
I understood natural language processing
and I didn't understand that much about
starting a business I mean you know my
co-founder and I who I will talk about
in a minute we're both technical
co-founders okay so everything to do
with sales and marketing and business
operations and fundraising was all
really really new to me I started
writing a lot when I decided to leave
big companies didn't know what I wanted
to do didn't know I wanted to start a
company of my own but a bunch of these
got some press I started blogging quite
a bit and I started writing a lot about
statistical measurement of bias right so
I did a study when I was at Amazon I
don't know if I was a very good employee
at Amazon because I mostly sat in
meetings logging how many times men and
when
women interrupted each other and then I
published it in Slate her that happy I
published a piece right as we were
getting started that in unfortunate on
bias in performance reviews and
technology that was really fortuitous
because it went hyper viral and it ended
up formative in in text iou's history um
i blogged I had little comic strips of
me and my daughters that I drew on the
blog if that blog is still there but now
most of my blogging is at Tech Co um but
you know I was really writing a lot
again always an engineer always a writer
when Jensen and I decided to start tech
Co we had a really clear vision okay and
I'll talk a little bit about his
background in a bit from everything we
had both done we had this idea it had
nothing to do with talent had nothing to
do with hiring it had nothing to do with
bias still doesn't but if anytime you
wrote anything at all okay just think
about this for a minute you're writing a
pitch to an investor you're writing a
sales email you're writing a job
description which is probably how you
know of us if you know of us if you knew
ahead of time who was going to respond
that would be super powerful right if
anytime you were writing you knew
exactly which aspects of your language
we're getting one group to engage while
another walked away then you could
change your approach right you could get
a different result before you published
it not after you published it and so
this thing we've come to call Augmented
writing we didn't have that language
three years ago really means writing
supported by masses and masses of data
where you know your engine can find the
patterns you know which words which
formats which constructions get one
group to engage while on the other walks
away that was really our founding
mission the very first thing we built
before before we had ever had funding
was a kickstarter predictor and
Kickstarter was a fantastic place to
prototype our technology because all the
projects are public
mein and all the outcomes are known so
you can look at the successful projects
and the unsuccessful projects and you
have a really good data set and so that
on the left is the first tech Co UI
Jensen our CTO drew that on a napkin
when we were in San Francisco and you
can see the first prototype we built
looks actually a lot like that and about
8 weeks into the company we had this
prototype working we got to 97%
predictive in minute 1 of a project as
to whether it was going to make money a
little depressing the quality of your
idea has a no bearing on whether you
make money on Kickstarter not at all as
a longtime product person that was
actually a little demoralizing but the
fonts you use how long it is where you
place your video content how you caption
your video content many of these things
are highly predictive of success so that
was really interesting and it felt like
we were onto something really big which
is the way you communicate can sometimes
even be more important than what you
communicate in getting to a certain
outcome so nine weeks into text EO we
raised our seed round with us this was
never gonna be a business right it was
never going to be like we're ready to go
out the door with a go to market plan of
helping Kickstarter entrepreneurs aren't
enough of them to make that a billion
dollar business but it proved that we
knew what we were doing and it worked
and so imagine you're in a room with a
bunch of investors and they all by the
way are familiar with Kickstarter they
all have a favorite campaign and you're
like so look it works no like no no go
find robot turtles how does that one
work what would you have said about that
no no go find you know the the potato
salad guy like what would it have said
about that is you have to do this over
and over again but it worked that was
our first office in another co-working
space that I will not name here the
Riveter didn't exist and on the right up
there those are the monitors we bought
for our team when we got our seed round
of one and a half million dollars we
made our teamwork without monitors we
worked without a lot of things it was a
huge day for us I guess we bought
monitors three years later we just moved
into a 25,000 square foot space downtown
we're like oh man this is big but that
is you know what we looked like in our
beginning which I'm sure for a lot of
you who are just getting started it's a
lot what you look like - so I'm gonna
walk through quickly five decisions that
either I made or we made together that I
think have accelerated our growth and
hopefully there's something useful in it
for you the first one may or may not be
repeatable but I started the company
with Jensen Harris who is our CTO he's
also my husband so you may not be able
to find that as a repeatable pattern so
that's our life right up in the left is
our like professional headshot which by
the way took a long time to get all of
our pictures will look a little like
family holiday photos and those are our
three daughters so we have three
daughters who are third grade second
grade first grade
yeah we're not we're not bored
Jensen's background is in always a
complement to mine so well I have been
deep in language and statistical
modeling and building software forever
Jensen was a musician he went to music
school but also like me had been coding
since he was three made his way through
college building shareware which again
like 20 years ago that was a thing and
really developed an industry-wide
reputation around user experience he
invented the first UI for email ever
right in the form of Outlook I led the
design and implementation of office
ribbon commanding in her face and then
Windows for the whole world so where I
had this experience you know really
understanding which how do you use an LP
machine learning to find patterns in
language I was really the backend
sensibility of the company he knew how
to build a user experience truly for a
billion people right we didn't have a
billion people we didn't have a million
people we still don't have a billion
people but you gotta aspire there you
got it you got to build it so it's
usable by people who are not linguist
not engineers not data scientists the
fact that we've done this together
wouldn't work for every family but for
us it is an incredible foundation
because there's no one I trust more
right so if he picks something up I know
it's good and if it's not he's gonna
tell me and vice versa and we have very
different strengths so that's been a
decision by the way didn't make it
easier to raise money the first time
around there's certainly some people who
didn't want to invest in us because we
had you know the family relationship
that we have didn't make a difference in
the a or the B so just remember that if
you get over the hurdle people look at
what you can do together and you have
investors kind of in your camp so
whether you're co-founding with your
spouse or not I really like what Kristin
said in the last panel co-founding is an
amazing choice solo founding i look at
what amy nelson is doing here with three
babies under four and she's a solo
founder and like hats off to you that is
hard co-founder gives you someone to
rely on and you need even if they're not
your spouse they're a little bit like
your spouse and you really need to have
that that trust so that's kind of the
first decision that really I think was
how we got started that really
accelerated us okay
the second important decision was the
decision to start with job posts so as I
mentioned we got started we built a
Kickstarter predictor as nothing to do
with talent or bias but remember I was
publishing quite a bit about really HR
documents and documents about people and
bias we knew and still know that in six
seven years from now when we IPO we want
you writing everything with text EO we
want you writing every single thing at
work with text EO it is a bold ambition
we are gonna take down Microsoft Word
and Google Docs and we can do it because
we've had the opportunity to run those
products you got to start small as a
start-up if you're making something
that's really really predictive right
that actually when you type in a word
processor cat talked about XE was
analyzing job post is actually more for
writing job posts you need to give
guidance that specifically works for the
kind of writing that is at hand so we
realized early we had a lot of
opportunity because I had a lot of
relationships and talent and HR because
of work I was publishing to do something
really good for that audience they
had a problem they're spending a lot of
time and money recruiting and making
recruiting content they're not happy
with how it performs both from a time to
hire perspective and certainly a
diversity and inclusion perspective they
had data about the problem so they have
a masses of job posts and they keep
track of how those job posted with real
people and we had a technology and so
the decision to start with job post was
really essential so focusing that broad
vision in on a place where we could
deliver value for companies okay so you
could actually prove that the platform
works we had unique relationships to get
us started so if we had started out in
sales and marketing which by the way
every investor that we first talked to
asked us why we weren't starting there
because there's a lot of money in sales
and marketing we would have been choked
out right as the head of an HR tech
product I get to go meet with CEOs of
Fortune 100 companies because they care
about that problem and it's a very
underserved population technologically
if we had built something in sales and
marketing to start I would have been
just another sales enablement CEO right
so find the place that is uniquely you
that you can win we started here because
we thought we could win deliver value
and at the same time it's had this
stealth benefit which is by the way in
all of our companies so you think about
a company like Apple or Cisco or Johnson
& Johnson because they're mostly an
enterprise product everybody in that
company is using text EO because every
job function hires and so when we're
ready with products for those other
domains they know us in fact one of our
challenges is people try to give us data
for other domains ahead of our desire to
be in those domains because remember
your startup we're still only 65 people
right you got to focus
you got to do something you can do
uniquely well and win so for us this was
a really good place to begin the series
B we raised last year is the recognition
that the platform works and we're ready
to start attaching it to other kinds of
writing and then of course there's the
wonderful benefit that actually you can
solve some really significant bias
problems for companies to which is
really important to us as Kat mentioned
our companies half women are exact teams
half women our board is more than half
women we live this
let's get through the third really big
decision we made is around rebranding so
in 2000
in 2014 that's what our logo looked like
and in 2016 we rebranded and it really
is very stark contrast before and after
the one on the right looks like an
enterprise product it wasn't just about
the look and feel though it's also how
we talked about the product so our
director of brand experience when he
arrives at the company observed that our
team when we were selling the product
was talking too much about how easy it
was to use and it is easy to use right
that's that's Jensen's contribution in
history but no one buys something
because it's easy to use no one gives
you a quarter million dollars for
something because it's easy to use like
a skateboard plus keep worried about
example not easy to use like these shoes
are easy to use you buy it because of
the value it provides to you so he
really made the observation that we were
pitching the company and the product
wrong we were pitching about ease-of-use
which is our a strength of ours but
actually we should pitch the fact that
when companies use the product they fill
their jobs two weeks faster or they get
23% more women into the pipeline for
engineering and technology roles that's
why people buy the product and so all of
the rebranding and the way we talk about
the product have contributed to an
acceleration for us because people read
it differently you buy it when you saw
the value that was an important decision
the other thing I learned is somebody
with a product background is that the
product isn't only what you build it's
also how you package and sell it so when
we started out very first thing we did
was we had an invite-only beta we ran
that for 12 weeks once we got you know
five months into the company we had
built this beta for job descriptions we
had early prospective customers who were
sharing data with us we figured that out
the beta went well and so we decided to
commercialize we didn't know anything
about how to commercialize so we did
what a SAS company might do is we're
like here go on our website you can buy
a seed of text EO for
$59 a month or something for yourself
which is really cheap for the value
people loved it because it was really
cheap and they went and they bought the
product and that was seemed really
exciting until we tried to get back into
those bigger mid market or Enterprise
sales where they're like well we could
just buy like three or four seats and
we're good our team can share them
that's not good for building a scalable
business so we shifted the model and
today the way we saw the product is with
a flat fee according to the number of
jobs you have open at the time you
subscribe so if you have a thousand jobs
open you pay a flat fee for 12 or for 24
months and you add as many people as you
want in fact you should out everybody
because the product will work better for
you as a machine-learning company that's
super important to us because we're
learning from more writers in the
platform and of course in terms of our
sustainable revenue that's more
important to us because we shift the
value away from the individual writer to
the value of the platform what's it
doing for your company I can't even tell
you and I had no sales background at all
I we were our first six people were all
technical at the company I wrote a lot
of the original back-end of the product
but I was the only one who wanted to
talk to people which is how I ended up
being the CEO and I certainly how I
ended up being the first sales person so
I ran sales customer engagement
basically for a year before we hired our
next person and you can't imagine my
shock the first day we received a paper
check in the mail for $35,000 from my
first enterprise sale like what do I
even do with a paper check like it's it
was 2015 I didn't even know how to get
it into our bank account cuz it never
occurred to me people would pay that way
it was like sitting around the office
like a hot potato for a few days we were
all like oh my god someone's gonna lose
it's gonna get what are we gonna do most
people don't pay with paper checks
although that customer on their third
year of renewals still pays with paper
checks luckily is no longer my job to
take care of the paper check not where I
excel but you know this was a really
important decision for us changing the
way we licensed the product you can see
what
happened in our a revenue graph you can
see the before and after you can see
that we were going along and then you
can see we're we went right up and our
customers were happier too because it
made sense to them they got it they
didn't want to have to limit usage
that's not good you want your whole
recruiting and talent and hiring team to
do it so pricing it in a way that made
sense to them and by the way allows them
to not worry about who they're giving
access to really worked for us so think
about when you first are licensing your
product remember that the way you price
it and license it is just as big a part
of the product itself as the actual
thing you're making really really
important we also figured out how to
make it a better value proposition for
our customers to share more and more of
their outcomes data with us the longer
their customers so they have a lot of
incentive to share data already because
the product works better for them and
they if they do right so they don't have
to just use everybody else as aggregate
model today tech SEOs job engine is
about three hundred and fifty million
jobs with outcomes attached so we're
adding about 10 million a month how do
you do that you do that with your
customers right the customers are our
deep partners in this and this was a
really important piece here which is
that they provide their data the
platform learns the guidance in the
platform gets better for them as they
write they use it we all measure
together again it creates this virtuous
cycle and if their data partners they
pay less to use the platform because
they're helping us make it they're part
of our family that's been a huge
advantage for us finally the press has
been really kind to us since we started
I think we because we got out of the
gate early showing some impact for
diversity and inclusion the press was
really excited I was writing quite a bit
so I had some connections but one thing
we learned over our first couple of
years is that not all good coverage is
actually good for your business so this
is what the first some sampling of what
like the first year of tech CEO press
looked like these are great brands right
you
the New York Times writing about you
Bloomberg writing about you fortune
writing about you they're all writing
about texty oh it's awesome in a really
narrow way they're not telling the story
of Augmented writing they're talking
about bias and we care about bias we
collaborated with them on a number of
these stories some of them are based on
blogs that we did but we realized about
a year into the company that if we're
gonna deliver on the bigger vision we
need to change the narrative we want
these stories this is important to us
but we don't want to be pigeonholed as a
bias play that's not what we are we're
writing play so we worked really really
hard over the following year or two and
Marissa who's our director of columns is
here today and really led a lot of this
work to change the narrative these are a
couple of examples of pieces we've had
that have broken pretty big we started
talking about other aspects of hiring
language we started talking about what
does it matter what does it mean if you
have grammar errors and your job post is
it gonna change their performance by the
way it doesn't I don't know if that's
good or bad it doesn't
we have piles of data about the public
job post of every company in the world
and text EO knows the patterns that are
culturally distinctive in those
environments so and there's a lot of
Amazonians here but amazon jobs are see
if we can see it 33 times more likely to
contain wickedly and it's not all
wickedly prime but when you see things
like you know maniacal wickedly
fast-paced environment show up in job
posts it's not an accident if a bunch of
people in your company are using the
same language
it's your culture so we've started
telling bigger stories about writing and
culture and that's been really important
for us when I got to be on Bloomberg TV
last year I was talking about Augmented
writing what it means for the future of
digital writing and yes we absolutely
talked about the fact that when
Expedia's jobs are gender neutral they
fill three weeks faster that's awesome
right not an accident you reach the
whole population of course you find the
qualified person more quickly but people
are interested in us now for the bigger
story so we started small
and we've been broadening as we go um
and you can see just in the last six
months since we really brought this term
big people are talking about Augmented
writing as the category and it's the
category we're creating so this is
fantastic this is what we want it so
hopefully there's something in here you
can learn from
if I were recapping I only have like a
minute left
pick that co-founder very very
thoughtfully if they're not your spouse
they're gonna feel like your spouse my
case I'm lucky because he's actually my
spouse and he's awesome
start small pick a problem that you
cannot only make traction on but you're
confident you have unique skills to win
because you know what if you don't win
early you don't win you got to pick a
place you know that you can win and then
be really mindful of the fact that your
product is also how you license it not
just what you build and the stories you
tell about yourself change how people
see you what they're willing to pay for
you and aim big don't let anybody put
you in a kind of a small box if you
start out in a small box because you're
trying to make progress that's a choice
you're making it's not a choice that
investors get to make on your behalf
it's not a choice that the ecosystem
gets to make on your behalf so thank you
[Applause]
you